why yesterday that's a good question and
I think for the Browns you know two of
the last three games you had the
Steelers game and the Chargers game that
really were kind of ugly performances
and for this team it's such a young team
and while we all know it's been brutal
the last couple of years they've showed
some signs of life and I think when John
Dorsey and Jimmy and D Haslam sat down
and looked at everything I think they
realized that a change had to be made
and they obviously with it both being
head coach Hugh Jackson and offensive
coordinator Todd Haley I think they felt
that the environment that was being
created was not the right one for Baker
Mayfield who is the franchise or the
rest of this young team and so you heard
talks yesterday about internal discord
and I think they just wanted to make
sure this is an organization that is
functioning I mean I've been there six
years I have seen regimes come and go
I've seen infighting in the past and I
think with John Dorsey there along with
the Haslam's now they said no more of
this we're not having it anymore it's
time for a change and I will say I think
you Jackson in many ways was dealt a
very unfair hand at least in his first
two years you know where he finished one
in 31 and I think that that Albatros
whether it was just or not was too big
and too big for the fan base and too big
for the team and so when you had that on
top of what was going on in the building
with you and Todd Haley I think they
just said you know what it's enough the
the priority number one is developing
Baker Mayfield and this young team and
we need to put them in the best
environment possible going forward but
you have these two coaches take a
selfish approach here Hugh Jackson and
Todd Haley native I knew that Todd Haley
was gonna be combustible and not gonna
work out they had to know inside even
though he's a great offensive mind and
you're bringing him in to help Baker
Mayfield he also have to have two guys
who get along when did this relationship
get fractured or was it ever a
relationship you know I think that's
that's a million-dollar question Dan and
I would say that in this business as you
well know being around so many people in
the NFL and even in your business and
broadcasting there are so many egos
involved and huge accident made it to
the point that he was the head coach of
the Cleveland Browns by being the NFL's
assistant coach of the year as an
offensive coordinator for the Cincinnati
Bengals back in 2000
fifteen Todd Haley has presided over the
number two offense in the NFL for the
last six years with the Pittsburgh
Steelers so I would imagine both of
those guys would think hey I know how to
do this as well as anybody on the planet
and I think that setup you know was
difficult for you last year he had so
much honestly was the head coach he was
the offensive coordinator who was trying
to handhold the Shawn Kaiser who was not
ready to play through an entire season
and I think this year they thought it
would be a good idea to take some things
off the plate but you could see I think
from the beginning and even on Hard
Knocks that you know this might be a
tough a tough relationship to have go
smoothly
unless there's you know without question
success and I think when things started
to go badly and I think the last three
weeks we certainly saw the offense
regress in fact last week you know you
go into the middle of the fourth quarter
with minus one yards of offense in the
second half and the comments you made
following the Tampa Bay game where he
said he was going to get involved which
were born out of frustration I think at
that point you knew something had to
give and yesterday being in the building
in berea I into hew who I would consider
a friend of mine and you know I was felt
awful for him but we were on the air
doing Cleveland Browns daily at about
107 when the first report came out about
Todd Haley so yesterday I was kind of
shocked I thought it might be an
either/or and they're going to review
one person out and try to go forward but
John Dorsey in Haslem said nope we've
had enough and both guys are out
yesterday
Howard trying to business job it should
be very attractive I think that anybody
you know who would look at the recent
history of the Browns and coaches and
and say to themselves man this you know
it seems like a job destined for failure
but I think if you take a step back
you've got a great football leader now
in John Dorsey and you've got a great
young roster you think about the most
important positions in sports you've
gotten your young quarterback in Baker
Mayfield you've got arguably the best
young pass rusher in the league and
miles Garrett who just set a franchise
record for the most sacks through 8
games of the year
Denzel Ward is your young lock down
corner who has looked great out of Ohio
State he's the fourth pick overall you
know everywhere you look on this team
it's first and second year players very
few guys even into their fifth or sixth
season season so you have a young roster
with a lot of talent on it David Ajoke
who's an ascending player Larry okay
Joby's having a great year for you
upfront Jabril peppers is coming into
his own so everywhere you look you have
a very talented young roster that is
going to be together the nucleus of
which will be together for at least
three or four more years and you'd
obviously like to extend those guys
beyond that so I do think it's an
attractive job I think they're gonna
need somebody who can come in and be so
discipline oriented and focused on all
the details and really the most
important thing I think ultimately you
need to bring somebody in here who is
the right guy for Baker Mayfield I think
you would agree we're seeing an absolute
shift in the way offenses are running
the National Football League and it
started with Sean McVeigh Andy Reid Matt
Maggie now in Chicago what Carmichael is
doing with Sean Payton down in New
Orleans that's the future of the NFL and
I think it will be important for the
Browns to get somebody that can put
Baker Mayfield who is an ideal
quarterback for that style offense into
that kind of a system going forward
should be mentioned that Nathan was
suspended for how many games were you
suspended for that would be eight games
to left I will be back on the sidelines
for the Cincinnati Bengals game
following Thanksgiving and for that I
will in fact to be thankful and you were
suspended because I questioned the
veracity of a call on the sidelines and
I would say this I let my passion for
this team and you know it's been very
hard and you know I'm a passionate
person dan I let my passion for the team
get the best of my judgment and and now
I am doing the time for the crime what
can't can't they just flag you white who
suspended it would have been worse I
think if I'd gotten flag I think that
might have been a heck of a lot worse
and who suspended you the NFL the Browns
the Brown oh okay
do you think the NFL told told the
Browns to suspend you I I don't want you
to get in more trouble good to talk to
you Nathan great talking with you guys
as well and love the front row gentlemen
I'm joy Nathan Segura for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel two
three
nine on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]